ahora vamos buenos días
y empezamos con la obligada pregunta
retórica
en cuanto esté él es gigante en la mano
han volado alguna vez era miembros
cantos todos querían
a
[Música]
con mis cosas de mi isla ver cosas por
hacer
[Música]
es gas estar en torno a ver como que
saliendo bien del auditorio es un rayo
literal
es más anualmente hay más personas que
se lastiman con pelear con magia pero
las
a 10 pesos
las tijeras lástima por eso siente
lástima por accidente esa dirección
así de seguros al día de hoy viajar
diariamente
[Música]
en 1948
la fuerza del estado
[Música]
a 17
imposible
el fuselaje y los botones las hélices
los alerones se dieron cuenta que las
condiciones
[Música]
y simulaciones
entonces cuál era el problema
[Música]
son diferentes a los pilotos
es de hecho mi historia
todo
pero no
[Música]
una vez
de piezas como
de dos euros morea oreja más bien
despidió todo sacado un promedio de las
permite las peticiones que hicieron las
diez medidas más importantes
pero
pero no
en
y siempre tomar fiesta
3 solamente 144 minutos o sea el 3.5 es
un fracaso
más o menos por esas mismas fechas antes
[Música]
la mujer
y qué pasa por qué no explica entender
[Música]
después inclusiones ascendentes feliz y
no me existiera la involución y también
sin conocida de sus famosos piel que
religión procesar ya y llega a tener
tanto después increíbles aledaños como
norma la mujer perfecta la mujer linda
entonces hace un concurso de belleza
tres mil 800 mujeres la misma cantidad
de calor
ah
a saber el mil por milímetros porque al
final pues está medidas promedio
por qué
50 que en menos de 40 de ellas empataron
habitantes posee el 1 por ciento
impensable está pasado
no existe
[Música]
esas velocidades
no existe
[Música]
y por supuesto
la mujer
y las habilidades de los conocimientos y
las aptitudes promedio el promedio no
existe cualquier sistema que esté
diseñado para funcionar para el promedio
está destinado a fracasar pero ustedes
y entonces
bien
y siempre existió cuántos de ustedes
renunciaron a su sueño cuando les
bajaron
o peor aún en cuanto están pensando en
eso
las 30.000 no hacemos la mayoría de
nosotros
los galeses tan ambiciosos que nadie les
puede alcanzar y poder llevar un precio
que si quieres procura mejorar los los
más peligrosos podemos ser por nosotros
mismos es quieren pretende usar el
promedio con tiempo de verlo existe
porque atenta contra mentar la
individualidad contaminarse ser únicos
contra los que nuestros especiales
contar nuestros sueños hagas lo que
hagas no quieras
[Aplausos]
[Música]